hey everyone it's Sarah dredge Turner
sorry and calm and in this video I'm
going to be going over long auscultation
specifically the sites of where you
auscultate and I'm going to be going
over normal breath sounds versus
abnormal breath sounds and as always you
can access the quiz and the notes over
here or in the description below now in
the next video I'm going to be
performing an assessment on a patient
and show you how to listen with your
stethoscope to these sites so let's get
started first let's talk about our
objectives of this lecture what I want
you to learn is lung anatomy because
it's really important you know what
you're listening to the specific
auscultation size I'm going to give you
some landmarks to make your job easier
so you'll know what intercostal space
correlates with which lobe of the one
and we're going to go over some audio
clips of normal breath sounds and where
you should hear them out so that's a big
thing you should know where you should
hear wrong field verses vesicular and
we're going to go out over abnormal
breath sounds and I'm going to let you
listen to the end and you can compare
the two so first let's go over lung
Anatomy whenever your auscultate in
you're going to be listening to the
anterior part of the test and the
posterior part of the chest now one
thing you want to remember whenever
you're listening to anterior mostly what
you're going to be hearing a lot of
because it's predominantly in the
anterior part are the upper lobes
however on the posterior part what is
predominately made up on this is the
lower lobes so first let's take a look
of the anatomy of the anterior part of
the chest in this illustration you have
your right lung and your left lung and
how I set up this illustration is that I
wanted you to be able to see what is
over the lungs because whenever you're
listening with your stethoscope you need
to know where clavicle is and certain
intercostal spaces because they
correlate to which lobe of the lung
you're listening to for instance if
you're listening down in
the sixth intercostal space mid-axillary
you're assessing the lower lobes of the
right and left lung which we'll go over
in depth whenever I cover these
auscultation sites so first let's cover
the right lung your right lung is made
up of three lobes very important so you
have your right upper lobe then you have
your right middle lobe and right here
you have the horizontal fissure and then
you have the oblique fissure and this
just separates the middle lobe from your
upper and your lower and then down here
you have your right lower then over here
you have your left lung you have your
left upper lobe and B in your left lower
lobe and if you notice in the drawing
mainly whenever you're listening to your
lungs you're mainly going to be
assessing because you can see more of it
of your upper lobe then we have our
trachea which is up here and it goes
down and it branches off into your
bronchus your bronchi and then your
bronchi go even further and branch off
into bronchioles with your IV Oller sacs
and this is where gas exchange occurs
and then of course you have your
breastbone and all your ribs right here
now let's look at the posterior view of
the lung here is the posterior view of
the patient's back if you were to look
inside look at the lungs you'll have the
clavicle on the front then it comes
around and it forms into your scapula
and you have your less lung and your
right lung they were on their flip then
compared to the anterior view and here
as you can see you have mostly lower
lobe that you're assessing and it's
separated by your fissures here so you
have your right upper lobe and you have
your right lower lobe notice you can't
really assess the middle lobe like as
you can with anterior view and then over
here you have your left upper lobe and
your left lower lobe and you have your
spine in the middle and it's really
important you find c7 to t10 whenever
you're assessing which we'll go over in
the auscultation site because this will
help you
where to place your stethoscope in
between the spine and the scapula on
those intercostal spaces right in
between the ribs where you start
listening to a patient's lung let's talk
about some tips to make your job easier
so you can get the best sound possible
be able to assess those lungs correctly
okay first tip listen directly on the
patient's chest with the diaphragm of
your stethoscope that is the big part of
the sub scope which you'll see a little
bit later and the reason you want to
listen directly on the skin and not over
close is because a lot of times your
diaphragm can rub up against the
patient's clothes and that can make like
a rustling sound sound like one there's
adventitious lung sounds and it'll
muscle and decrease the sound quality of
what you're trying to hear also whenever
you're listening on women you'll want to
have the woman raise up her breast so
you can get underneath those sites so
you can hear those lungs sounds because
the tissue will muffle the noise and you
won't be able to hear that so remember
that whenever you're listening on a
female patient also whenever you're
listening to the chest you're going to
listen to the both the front and the
back side and whenever you're listening
you're going to note a full cycle of
inspiration and expiration and what
you're listening for is you're listening
to the pitch is it highs in a medium or
low pitch what's the sound quality and
its duration is is inspiration longer
than expiration or vice versa or are
they equal which are characteristics of
normal breath sounds and on that sound
that you're hearing is there any extra
adventitious sounds that shouldn't be
there maybe on inspiration or expiration
so you really want to note that and
whenever you listen you're going to
start from the top and work your way
down and you're going to compare sides
so be something like this I'm going to
start up here at the apex of the lung
listen here and then you're going to go
over and with
on the other side to compare it then
you're just going to drop down a little
bit listen here and then you're going to
go over here and compare sides drop down
again and just keep repeating until
you've reached the bottom another thing
what you want to do to help get the best
sound quality is have the patient
sitting up so you can get to the front
and the back of that chest post cheerily
because this is an area that may give
you trouble because as we went through
the anatomy you have your spine here and
you have the scapula here so if you have
the patient sort of move their arms
forward maybe in their lap to separate
those shoulder blades you can get in
those little intercostal spaces better
so you can put your diagram and listen
to those sounds also whenever you're
having the patient breathe you want them
to breathe in and out through their
mouth slowly so you can hear those lungs
inflate and deflate however and a lot of
patients who may have breathing
difficulties you'll have to take your
time within because they can
hyperventilate easily and make sure your
patient doesn't get dizzy and just take
your time while you're having them
breathe now let's go over the
auscultation sites okay first we're
going to assess the anterior part of the
chest first and what I like to do is I
find the clavicle and we're going to
start at the apex of lungs and talk to
the lungs and we're going to get our
diaphragm which is the big part of your
stethoscope and you are going to place
it right slightly above that clavicle
where the apex is you're going to listen
there for a full inspiration and
expiration and then you're going to go
over and compare on the other side and
this is listening to the apex of the
lungs then you're going to find your
second intercostal space this is one of
those landmarks we're talking about
because this is going to assess our
upper lobes of our right and left lung
and this is found midclavicular Lise in
the middle of where the clavicle is in
the second intercostal space so you
listen here compare your side and then
just go a little bit lower maybe into
the third intercostal space
and just keep listening to those upper
loads then we're going to go down to our
fourth intercostal space this is another
big landmark for specifically the right
middle lobe so we're going to go down to
our fourth intercostal space we're still
in the left lobe in the upper lobe and
now we're going to go over here and
compare sides now we're in the right
middle lobe and this again is mid
clavicular lis and we're listening in
here and then we'll just inch a little
bit down maybe in the fifth and still
assess our right middle lobe and then
we'll go over and compare sides still
being in the upper lobe on the left side
now we will inch down to the sixth
intercostal space but mid axillary so
we're there armpit is go Midway and
we're down in the lower lobe of the
lungs and we'll have them inhale and
exhale and then we'll go over and
compare it on the other side which we're
in the right lower lobe here and
assessing this and then we'll just into
a little bit down maybe to the seventh
space down the lung and just listen and
those lower lobes a little bit more and
compare sides and then we're done now
let's look at our sites on post ears
just like with anterior and the
posterior we're going to start from top
to bottom and compare sides and work our
way down and we're going to start right
above the scapula right where the apex
is so we're going to listen here and
then we're going to go over to the other
side and compare and remember to get the
best sound quality so you can hear so
you're not listening over the shoulder
blades because that won't muffle your
salmon you won't be able to hear have
your patient put their arms in their lap
or just separate those shoulder blades
from each other so you can get in
between that spine and shoulder blade
area then what we're going to do we want
to assess first your upper lobes
so from c7 to t3 your cervical and
thoracic spine that is where your upper
lobes or and
you can see here's your Fisher's right
here and you have the upper lobes there
so what you want to do is just go in
between where the shoulder blades and
the spine are and just work your way
down so we're going to listen to your
upper lip so we'll go here and then
we'll compare over here and then we'll
go down a little bit towards where t3 is
listen here still being in the upper
lobe then we'll go over and compare
sides now from t3 to t10 that will allow
us to assess our lower lobes so we'll
start around t3 and work our way down
again just staying in between where the
scapula and the spine is and we will
just compare sides and enter way down
and you want to move around almost
mid-axillary where you were moving
before on interior so you can just get a
good feel for what's happening in those
lower lobes or so sorry not talking
about normal breath sounds okay there's
three different types a tip for whenever
you're trying to learn these normal
breath sounds is to get a stethoscope
listen to yourself or listen to others
and get a rhythm down for how long
inspiration expiration is and where
these are located because that's the key
with these three different sounds
because they're heard in different areas
throughout the lung field so let's go
over them
the first one is bronchial this is heard
anteriorly only you're not going to hear
this posteriorly anteriorly why because
they are mainly heard over the tracheal
area with the stethoscope so up here in
this area they are high-pitched and loud
and you will notice when you listen to
them that the inspiration will be
slightly shorter than the expiration and
this is what bronchial breath sounds
sound like next is bronchioles acicular
these are heard both anteriorly and post
eerily and they post eerily you will
hear these at the first and second
intercostal space so about in this area
right in here with your stethoscope is
where you're going to hear them
anteriorly now post cheerily you're
going to hear them in between the
scapula so about right here where t3 t4
in the small little areas where you will
hear those and they will have a medium
pitch to them and inspiration and
expiration will be equal and here's what
Bronco vesicular sounds like
and the third breast sound is called
vesicular this is heard again and both
anteriorly and posteriorly and it is
heard throughout the peripheral lung
field so you're going to be hearing
these all throughout in this area over
here anteriorly and post tearily
and it will have a low pitch that will
be sort of soft and inspiration will be
greater than expiration and here is what
vesicular sounds like now let's talk
about those abnormal breast films that
you could hear that may be thrown in
with those normal breath sounds okay
they are separated into continuous and
discontinuous now first let's go over
continuous what does continuous mean
this is a extra sound that you're
hearing that is lasting more than 0.2
seconds with a full respiration okay the
first type is called a high pitch
polyphonic wheeze let the name help you
okay so what is it it is mainly heard in
expirations when the patient's breathing
out but it can be an inspiration as well
and it is a high-pitched musical
instrument sound with many different
sounds to it that's why it's polyphonic
and this is what a high pitch polyphonic
wheeze sounds like
another type of ways you can have is
called a low pitch monophonic wheeze and
this is again heard mainly an expiration
but you can hear at any time but a lot
of times you'll hear it whenever the
patient's breathing out it is a low
pitch whistle so instead of being
high-pitched like the high-pitched
wheezing to be low and it's going to be
made up of one sound quality that's all
you're going to be hearing and it can
sound like a whistle or a whine and this
is why a low pitch monophonic wheeze
sounds like and the third type of
continuous adventitious breath sound is
called Strider and this is heard on
inspiration because what's happening is
that the airway is being obstructed by
inflammation or some foreign objects
something like that and once you hear
this you will never forget it's very
unique sounding it is a high pitch
whistling or gas with a very harsh
quality to it and on patients like
pediatric patients if they get the croup
or a cute epiglottitis or you have a
patient who has an airway obstruction
you will hear this sound and this is
what Strider sounds like now let's get
over the second type of breath sound
abnormal breath sounds called
discontinuous this is an extra sound
that you're hearing that is lat lasting
less than 0.2 seconds
okay first type is coarse crackles
crackles formerly have been known as
rels so if you hear that that's what it
means crackles rels they're interchange
just like rhonchi and weaves
so coarse crackles they are mainly heard
in inspiration when the patient's
breathing in and can extend into
expiration and what it will sound like
is a low pitch
wet slash bubbling sound and this is
what course crackle sounds like the
second type of discontinuous abnormal
sound is called fine crackles this is
heard on inspiration and it is a high
pitch crackling sound compared to the
coarse crackle this is like low pitch
like a bubbling noise this fine crackles
is high pitch it sounds completely
different than coarse crackles and it
has like a crackling of a fire sound to
it and the key with this is that it does
not clear when you have the patient call
so you listen you hear that
yes patient the coffin it's still there
that would be fine crackles and this is
what it sounds like and the last sound
is called a pleura friction rub this is
heard both on inspiration and expiration
and it is a low pitch harsh grating
sound and what's causing this is that
your pleura on your lungs those two
layers are rubbing against them each
other and they normally have this little
thin layer of serous fluid around the
lung but it doesn't right now due to all
that inflammation going on so you can
actually hear that when that patients
breathing in and breathing out so that's
why you're hearing it an inspiration and
expiration now it can sound similar to a
pericardial friction rub how do you tell
the difference and if you are wanting
stones this the lungs or is this the
heart just listen have the patient hold
their breath and if you can still hear
the harsh grating sound it's the heart
because they're holding their breath
their lungs aren't moving so you ruled
out the lungs and this is what it sounds
like
okay that is one auscultation and normal
breath sounds versus abnormal breath
sounds don't forget to take the free
quiz on the website and check out the
other videos in this series to help you
with lung auscultation and thank you so
much for watching and please consider
subscribing to this YouTube channel